[Music]
in my bad news
what he do submitted by sunny from
Minnesota any sunny unless it's coldest
[ __ ] over there is maybe Sun lose their
name yeah that makes sense from
Minnesota hmm yeah I thought they're
trying to say it's sad because I could
send some in California but you ain't
sending central Minnesota a man
accidentally recorded himself admitting
to killing a lawyer who sued him how the
hell do you do more he's really does he
admit that I think a lot of people think
about that but only mafias do it killed
the lawyer that sue this away didn't did
somebody else to him and he killed the
lawyer that won the case yeah I was just
trying to do his job you know lawyers
are just like messengers they take any
job she kill the other person yeah
people who try to sue people for no
goddamn reason all the time it
it's so [ __ ] annoying we just
recently had so one of my businesses got
caught into like this weird little
lawsuit yeah for no [ __ ] reason just
because like we're a part of the plaza
and they put our [ __ ] name on the the
lawsuit there was like you're supposed
to sue the [ __ ] management not every
business in the [ __ ] plaza dumbass
and they just lost obvious for obviously
yeah so is the dumbest [ __ ] thing I
think you're trying to sue anybody for
any amount of money and so like every
all the businesses names were on this
lawsuit that we're like why I'm here to
make a career off of just suing
something sticks well we gave it to the
lawyer they're like this is [ __ ]
that's what he said this is the dumbest
thing I've ever seen in my life yeah
yeah so this man is 80 year old man
named David he is now being charged with
first-degree murder and armed criminal
action and the killing of this lawyer so
this man David apparently he was he was
shooting at these four men because he
believed that these men were stealing
iron from his building because he builds
baby furniture and just
loaded I think he's about he's worth
about 33 million oh [ __ ] and so he lost
that case and so he was ordered to pay
5.7 million dollars to the lawyer and
stuff and like the who he practiced
personal injury law and so okay wait
wait hold on
so this guy ran a baby making baby stuff
making thing okay so he has a lot of
money so he thinks one day some people
are stealing from him and so he shoots
at them and then they sued him for
shooting at him yeah okay and then huh
and then he David lost so he had he was
ordered to pay fines this in California
no oh yeah that's uh did they go into
his furniture shop and they broke in
yeah that's what they're saying
that's [ __ ] ah I wasn't wrong there at
all on that maybe we don't know the
details they don't know the details just
sounds like he was just trying to
protect his [ __ ] and he was shooting and
I don't know or maybe they didn't
deserve to get shoot shot I don't know
yeah you know where the shooting
happened you don't know if it's like in
his compound outside of his compound
yeah what is they sue for emotional
distress like they'd be get hit there
are cases of people who broke into a
home got injured in this place in this
person's home out here in California and
then they [ __ ] got they won a lawsuit
because they sued the people Oh cuz
California doesn't have a castle law
well no they weren't even home they just
broke into the house and then they they
got injured in their home and then they
yeah and then they sued the homeowner we
don't have a castle law but there's
plenty of cases where people protect
their home we don't have a piece of
model either so you telling me I can
break into somebody's house and then
trip over some baby toys and then sue
them in California yeah so don't come to
my house you'll die the story that
they're really concentrating on here is
the fact that this lawyer was found shot
to death
the day after David was served with
properly property liens to satisfy that
5.7
because he wasn't trying to even pay it
yeah oh my god this is like the most
aggressive 80 year old man in the world
yeah he shot him after this lawyer came
back home from walking his kid to school
oh man
that's fire so it was like a mystery for
some time like they didn't know who
killed this lawyer until this idiot
he left this recording device on because
he was being he went to court and he
left it on he ended up just like
bragging you know someone's a wiretap
himself yeah he did cuz it he was like
people know that I murdered that son of
a [ __ ] and he was saying that he killed
a lawyer with a gun and got away with it
he did it because the lawyer stole his
money how did they get ahold of is oh
I've never a court yeah it's so inhuman
like sick people want to be glorified
for their crime so they can't help but
say [ __ ] it's weird you know anything
cuz like why I got him back yeah like
logically speaking you would think you
would kill this person and then you
would never speak of it again
to anybody I don't give a [ __ ] who it is
yeah but that's because I'm not a
murderer and I don't want to be
glorified for my [ __ ] I've read
somewhere before that vengeance is
usually a result of like ego and like to
kill the guy probably it helps balance
out his ego but then to talk about it
more just really reinforces his ego and
builds it up even more yeah I mean not
justifying it but I get why somebody
like why people keep talking about it
afterwards [ __ ] that for it's like that
I feel like this isn't his first murder
cuz he's so comfortable comfortable
shooting people yeah well he looks like
he's killed a lot during his younger
days yeah I believe it but he got away
with it because of no DNA and all that
stuff look at those bags under his
[ __ ] eyes my god your face is melting
they're like [ __ ] cash yeah one ring
for every murder you easy furniture
seller by day assassin by Michael my
grandpa didn't have much bags under his
eyes man
so Asian though yeah yeah that's right
because his face looks terrible it looks
like you left a pair out in the Sun I
think what happens to the pumpkins like
yeah you suck yeah you know so you're 80
years old you're worth thirty three
million someone takes five million now
buckets yeah good yeah now you got to go
to jail ego now you got to go to [ __ ]
jail and then you're gonna serve the
rest of your life there it's like give
it I don't know by that time by it by
eighty I'm just like I think you said he
probably killed I bet you he's killed
somebody in the past it's just another
day there's no brainer to me like old
people should never get a pass on
anything cuz just cuz you're old doesn't
mean you didn't do some stupid [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] I'm more scared of old people
cuz like because think about it he could
be a vet that killed 200 people or
whatever like if he might not be
affected by it yeah and old people are
tougher they just look softer it's just
like old people there are some [ __ ]
that's so true yeah like cars back in
the day you could sit on the hood and it
wouldn't Bend yeah they were [ __ ]
sturdy
hyoeun skillet vehicle yeah because if
you see somebody just like run up and
slide on a car today the whole [ __ ]
would be caved in yep true you know but
back in the day that [ __ ] was sturdy he
would smash somebody's face in it
nothing happens you know [ __ ] make up
like a lumberjack breakfast on it
sausage the bacon and that's like a big
ass walk losing weight so you went to
jail for how long
he's about to go to jail yeah
damn for the rest of his life I'm sure
he's not even mad about it he's like
yeah whatever [ __ ] it nah but if you if
you're a dude that lived at 33 million
dollar type of life
uh prison is not your [ __ ] bro and for
first-degree murder that's not even fed
prison that's not even satellite prison
that's like some hard time [ __ ] we've
used also a farmer I mean I don't know
if that paints him a little different
yeah thirty three million dollar farmer
though yeah if you go to jail did the
government take all your money or do
they like give it's like family or just
like frozen assets right he has a
daughter cuz they do mention in this
article that heat transfer he way there
are five million from his bank account
and
and like gave property to daughters or
something he withdraw Wow he just has
money like million yeah people there
like worth certain amounts and they
don't have money laying around like that
is [ __ ] damn dude mm-hmm
I think that's like Oh people do like a
lot of old folks they paid [ __ ] cash
like they don't use credit they don't
you know like first yeah like when they
buy homes they go yes how much is that
300,000 okay I'll write you a check I
will say this you know I am better with
money when it's cash cuz you could
physically see it leaving yeah that's
the majority of the people not me
ya mean with that card I just make sure
but if you got like let's say like
today's like well I'm living a lot to
eat but then you you have like this $100
bill you're gonna be very conscious of
how much that [ __ ] disappears when I'm
on my card on my swipe sleep so I am
irresponsible completely I had to get
rid of direct deposit I had to start
cashing my checks so I like like to
actually learn how to deal with my money
Amazon be [ __ ] me up man yeah I know
two days I'm so [ __ ] dumb - I just
like buying like new fresh [ __ ] like I
was thinking about the other day too
because I have like regular regular
boxing class outside to get my clothes
then I came back it's the same [ __ ] yeah
I'm like I'm like sitting that might bro
you suck you doesn't matter what you
have oh man I was like thinking about
getting all this cool [ __ ] I'm like
why'd you learn how to punch first you
dumb [ __ ] and I just closed my [ __ ] is
fun having cool [ __ ] I was ready to get
the shoes the belt like everything I'm
like alright tell me what I should get
that's what I'm saying even like that
cuz you not be like losing weight as
[ __ ] I'm like yo I need better workouts
like do you really bro like you don't
need like your clothes isn't gonna
depict like how will you why don't you
get your goal first and then you'll see
what happens you know II mean so I'm
like I feel like like stop doing that
[ __ ] because my [ __ ] Amazon wishlist
is ridiculous but sometimes buying the
dope [ __ ] after you have it it makes you
go on how to finish and actually do it
so I don't want to waste all that money
that's true - that's like some good
motivate sometimes it works I like like
dope like workout clothes I think
there's [ __ ] tight but then at the
same time I'm like you know you've done
this before so you might as well just
get like go
I don't want to set myself I'm almost
like afraid to jinx it because I've been
doing so well I don't want to jinx that
[ __ ] so now I'm just like I just doing
[Music]